on
[Musique]
chez les jeunes c'est les gens qui
arrivent pas à finir leurs fins de mois
qui sont dehors qui sont assommés de
taxes et qui n'en peuvent plus c'est
sale et gilet jaune
oui on n'est pas un parti politique on
n'est pas un syndicat mais c'est pas
exactement comment faire on n'est pas
organisée mais on n'est pas ni des
casseurs ni des gens qui réclament tout
et n'importe quoi on doit simplement
vivre normalement de notre salaire quand
on voit la précarité qui a partout au
niveau des retraités les jeunes les
études il a beaucoup qui peuvent pas
continuer parce que les parents n'ont
pas d'argent pour payer les études et/ou
puis de pouvoir d'achat le carburant du
sharan au nom en 36,6 sont battus pour
congés payés en 68 ils sont battus aussi
s'il faut que l'on arrive là elle pour
mac arriver mais faudra que le
gouvernement aux rouleaux type lille
aura pas le choix faut juste qu'ils
n'oublient pas une chose c'est nous les
citoyens
il fut néanmoins que rien qui mette en
but un anglais
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce
dimanche en politique spéciale gilet
jaune sur france 3 bourgogne et france 3
franche comté
cela fait quatre semaines maintenant que
la france est notre région sont gagnés
par la fièvre une fièvre jaune qui
paralyse north point nos zones
commerciales notamment une fièvre
soutenu d'après un sondage de vendredi
sondage opinionway soutenu par sept
français sur dix ce n'est pas rien alors
comment sortir de cette impasse quel
remède au malaise incontestable qui
gagne cette france des moins que rien
comme le disait mme gillet jaune
jurassienne
il y à quelques instants cette france de
nos villages de nos banlieues qui se
sent délaissé abandonné par un pouvoir
qui n'aurait d'yeux que pour les grandes
villes on va en débattre avec nos
invités dimanche en politique spéciale
ce matin sur france 3 bourgogne et
france 3 franche comté de gilet jaune
sont sur ce plateau ils vont pouvoir
interpeller en direct les élus les
représentants politiques qui sont à
leurs côtés mais d'abord direction dijon
la capitale régionale théâtre de fortes
tensions ces derniers samedi entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre
bonjour sébastien kérou vous êtes sur
place à dijon
le calme est il revenu ce dimanche matin
dans le centre-ville dijonnais
bonjour jérémy et bien effectivement
comme vous peut le voir derrière moi et
bien le calme est revenu ce matin dans
le centre ville de dijon
une situation qui n'a rien à voir avec
celle d'hier après midi puisque comme
vous le disiez et bien le secteur de la
place de la république et la rue de la
préfecture ont été le théâtre de
violences
et hier les rues de centre ville et
particulièrement là où je me trouve
était en fête inondée et envahie de gaz
lacrymogène alors pour remettre les
choses dans leur contexte et bien
rappelons à que 1500 gilet jaune s'était
rassemblée hier entre la place darcy et
la place de la république pour
manifester vers 16 heures la situation
s'est tendue avec un groupe d'une
centaine de casseurs qui s'est joint au
cortège des casseurs qui ont provoqué
les crs en leur jetant des projectiles
mais également en mettant le feu à des
poubelles et forcément et bien les crs
ont répliqué en lançant à des grenades
lacrymogènes sur la foule et certains
manifestants auraient même été victime
de tirs au flashball alors ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que la situation s'est
rétablie vers 18 heures lorsque
policiers et gendarmes ont quadrillé le
secteur de la place de la république et
de la rue de la préfecture pour
disperser la foule mais le bilan de ce
samedi est à 6 triste puisque six
personnes ont été interpellées neuf
personnes ont été blessées et côté
matériel et bien
plusieurs vitrines ont été cassées car
vous le verrez les commerçants eux aussi
ont beaucoup souffert de ce mouvement d
gilet jaune
merci merci sébastien on viendra vous
voir tout à l'heure avec justement des
commerçants retour en plateau donc je
vous présente tout de suite nos invités
avec deux filets jaunes sur le plateau
de dimanche en politique céline roy vous
êtes l'une des chevilles des chevilles
ouvrières du mouvement à vesoul
également sur ce plateau
fabrice schlegel l'un des initiateurs
des gilets jaunes dans le secteur de
dole
vous allez pouvoir interpeller les élus
les représentants politiques qui sont
également présents sur ce plateau
notamment barbe
rabaisser au balo député la république
en marche de haute saône
yanbu car députés les républicains du
territoire de belfort également sur ce
plateau jacques ricart des ti conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté
maire de tresses ans dans une petite
commune du doubs vous êtes membre du
rassemblement national
et puis sandrine veillait seront
présents séverine séverine vieillesse
représentante de la france à ce weed à
besançon bonjour à tous les six merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors vous en avez l'habitude cette
émission c'est aussi la vo devant votre
télévision vous pouvez interpeller nos
invités réagir en direct sur la page
internet de dimanche en politique sur le
site de france 3 bourgogne franche comté
je me ferai le relais de vos questions
tout au long du débat et puis vous
pouvez commenter cette émission sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le mode ia ce qui
s'affiche dit mme paul bfc comme
dimanche en politique bourgogne franche
comté alors céline roy vous êtes donc
une des figures du mouvement des gilet
jaune à vesoul on vous suit depuis
quatre semaines
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire qui
vous êtes et pourquoi vous êtes entrés
dans le mouvement
alors moi je suis scellé le roi je suis
maman de trois enfants commercial
itinérant dans ma profession
j'ai commencé
ben comme tout le monde sauf en région
de la manif le 17 novembre
et vu l'impact que ça a eu ce que j'ai
pu entendre le 17 novembre c'était
inconcevable pour moi de rentrer chez
moi elle dira que j'avais fait ma béat
du jour et que j'allais pas continuer
ensuite mais pourquoi vous êtes allés
manifester bas parce que je suis maman
de trois enfants
je n'ai pas à me plaindre je touche un
salaire correct et c'est dans la vie je
suis commercial
mais ce que j'entends autour de moi mes
frais au plus haut point quand j'ai des
copines qui sont aussi maman qui
n'arrive pas à finir les fins de mois
alors qu'elle travaille d'arrache-pied
mes grands-parents qui on touche une
retraite de misère à qui on reprend
encore de l'argent dessus alors qu'on ne
devait pas toujours traitent ils n'y
arrivent plus non plus donc la situation
devient plus qu'urgente donc c'est
d'abord le pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir
d'achat les retraites du sionisme il ya
le gasoil qui a fait exploser un petit
peu tout ça mais derrière il ya un
sérieux problème de fond on l'a vu les
images qu'on voit du mouvement des gilet
jaune ces derniers jours se sont
beaucoup des images de casseurs
est-ce que vous condamnez les violences
qui a eu notamment dans notre région
alors on a parlé de dijon il ya quelques
minutes
mais il ya eu des débordements hier
aussi à besançon il ya eu des
affrontements avec les lycéens il ya
quelques jours à montbéliard beaucoup de
villes de bourgogne franche comté sont
concernées alors pour moi les casseurs
ne sont pas gage il a joué tout
simplement moi je depuis dix-sept choix
vesoul on a eu aucun débordement
sait on est totalement pacifistes et on
condamne bien sûr tout ce qui a pu se
passer à paris là à dijon etc
c'est complètement absurde parce que
dans tous les cas c'est nous qui allons
payer tout ça c'est je pense que malgré
tout ça on peut encore passer par le
dialogue
peut-être plus pour longtemps mais pour
l'instant tu peux encore discuté avant
d'en arriver à une scène dramatique
comme ça fabrice légal autres gilet
jaune autres initiateurs du mouvement
vous sur le secteur de dole même
question cas c'est inné roi pourquoi est
rentré dans ce mouvement
moi je suis pas rentré dedans je les
crée c'est à dire qu'avec certains m'ont
donné fin octobre on s'est dit
il y en a assez de cette société poly
frac très polis facturé pardon où on
paye toujours toujours plus d'impôts
toujours plus de taxes pour toujours
moins de services on a une société où
l'imposition est devenu confiscatoire il
était temps de se lever
alors ça c'est fait grâce pas grâce ou à
cause de la tei cpe bien évidemment mais
c'est vraiment une taxe sur les produits
pétroliers et les sur les carburants
voilà et mais c'est quand même le mal
est beaucoup plus profond un et c'est
pour ça que d'ailleurs on trouvera pas
la solution aussi facilement que ça et
voilà pourquoi on s'est levés nous à
dole vous pouvez nous dire ce que vous
faites dans la vie je travaille dans la
construction je suis un artisan
promoteur immobilier avec des salariés
où vous travaillez ce que je travaille
tout en sous traitance
le mouvement revendique son côté à
politique c'est pas votre cas vous vous
avez été vous avez engagé à droite
je suis connue vous avez candidat est ce
que c'est candidats au départemental en
2015 pour la droite dans le canton dans
un des deux cantons de dole est ce que
votre situation n'est pas compliqué du
coup non du tout du tout vous assumez
votre engagement politique différente
par contre on a un socle commun c'est se
battre pour une société plus juste pour
une société qui ne laisse pas des gens
sur le côté etc
alors moi en tant qu'entrepreneur c'est
vrai que ce qui m'embête c'est que je
peux pas entreprendre dans ce pays sans
être permet d'impôts donc ça veut dire
que si je peux pas entreprendre au lieu
de faire 40 logements par an belge vont
faire que 20 pts
ce qui veut dire que au lieu de créer 50
emplois on en crée que 30
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de dire de
demander aux élus et notamment à la
représentant de la majorité
présidentielle quai sur ce plateau barbe
arabe et sauve à nos députés de la
république en marche
moi ce que j'aurais envie de demander à
madame beso c'est qu'est ce qu'attend
monsieur monsieur macro pour enfin
prendre ses responsabilités parce que
pour l'instant le climat insurrectionnel
qu'on convient où tous les samedis c'est
exclusivement de sa faute puisqu'il
suffisait d'apaiser les gens puisque les
mesures et de qu'ils ont annoncé cette
semaine s'il avait été faite le 18
novembre
je pense que beaucoup seraient rentrés
chez eux alors qu est ce qu attendent
monsieur macron pour enfin agir
véritablement marc barbé son vélo juste
avant de répondre à cette question là je
vais y répondre
je viens de la société civile comme vous
venez de l'indiquer j'ai l'impression
qu'on a les mêmes revendications je suis
arrivé en toute sincérité dont ce
mouvement qui n'est toujours pas
d'ailleurs un parti et on se revendique
mouvement dont le dogme de départ était
simplement de dire comment on fait pour
payer moins d'impôts au niveau général
tout en gardant le maximum de services
publics donc je crois qu'on est en train
de dire la même chose dans ce sens là
pour pouvoir répondre à cela puisque je
crois que nous disons tous la même chose
nous avons besoin d'une unité nationale
qu'est ce que j'entends par unité
nationale nous avons besoin de
déterminer les règles et d'y aller et
d'y aller puisque nous disons les mêmes
choses et c'est ce que vos proches
monsieur jeu légal c'est en gros un
retard à l'allumage par rapport au
mouvement
on est je crois qu'on s'est loupé avec
léon c'est manqué j'ai fait à peu près
une trentaine de réunions publiques sont
en territoire
j'ai pas vu grand monde j'ai pas vu que
vous n'avez pas senti cette grogne qui
s'exprime aujourd'hui la sur les
ronds-points la grogne qui se moquaient
la grogne qui a aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
a senti mois que j'ai senti en tout cas
il ya déjà un an et demi quand je suis
sorti effectivement de ma zone de
confort de ce que je pouvais vivre à
l'époque et et la vie en tout cas ne me
souriait donc il y avait aucun problème
par rapport à ça je n'ai pas fait sa
part en déduction j'ai fait ça vraiment
en toute conviction par rapport à ce que
ce que vous venez de dénoncer ici donc
par rapport à ses convictions là
effectivement c'est comme s'il y avait
un côté sentir trompé quand même là
illoul de nouveaux mondes à monsieur
macron nous sommes je vous le dis en
toute sincérité par une magie nous
sommes mais je n'ai je n'ai ni lui aucun
élément de langage avant de venir un
chien le préciser aussi j'ai tenté de
mâlain d'un autre côté on va pas vous
donner une médaille pour sa non c'était
avant que vous me le dis vous me disiez
c'est simplement j'ai tenté de venir ce
matin avec encore une fois le maximum de
sincérité d'abord avec moi même et aussi
avec ce pourquoi on s'est engagés
avec le les autres personnes qui sont
aussi en sortie de l'euro lors de
confort ce matin jeunes quand j'entends
jacqueline dubois directrice d'école qui
s'est fait brûler ses voitures juste une
vente chez elle benoît poterie qui est
un opticien qui a reçu une balle dans
une enveloppe et on lui dit la prochaine
elle est pour toi comment on peut pas
être inquiet comment alors qu'on se bat
pour les mêmes choses alors alors alors
ou et maquereau ou les maquereaux
c'était votre question je voudrais je
voudrais y répondent rapidement qu'on
fasse tourner la parole si oui macron
nous le faisons remonter aussi cette
colère et nous sommes au travail 1 et
pas dans le livre révolution mais
celui-là c'est celui là qui a changé ma
façon de voir parce que je ne n'ai
jamais été encarté politiquement
auparavant même si on fait tout ça et le
louvre h à 100 g d'emmanuel macron
pendant la campagne présidentielle
même si on fait tous de la politique
quand on est dans une association j'en
ai toujours fait en ce sens là de
maintenant
ce livre là on est en train de la mettre
en place est ce que vous n'avez pas vu
voulait gilet jaune et c'est ce que ce
que je tente d'expliquer comment que ça
se fait que vous n'avez pas vu qu'on
avait changé la fiche de paye comment
que ça se fait que vous n'avez pas vu
qu'on était passé du récit ou et c6 une
une jeune femme savait ce que j'ai vu
que les prix sont à 48,4 % en france
j'ai vu que ça a pas de diminuer j'ai vu
que la dépense publique a augmenté de 51
milliards j'ai vu tout ça manifestement
vous avez pas vu la même chose et c'est
là où se situe le problème
injustement nous récoltons aussi
quarante années de politique je dis
allez rencontrer ça nous récoltons çà et
là on tombe on va donner la parole aussi
aux autres politiques sur ce plateau
edouard philippe en milieu de semaine
est revenu
sur la hausse programmée des taxes sur
les carburants notamment ian bucarest
que l'opposition qui reprend à son
compte ces revendications des gilet
jaune notamment sur les hausses des
taxes sur le carburant se réjouit de
cette situation c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais je crois que ça aurait pu être
annoncé il ya quinze jours en fait nous
effectivement ces taxes sur le carburant
majeur fait campagne en janvier c'était
un événement de campagne pour la senti
très vite que ça allait peser près ma de
nombreux français je pense que si près
ministre à valence et à 15 jours saurait
régler un certain nombre de solutions
aujourd'hui soit le prix le président de
la république doit s'exprimer il doit
prendre la parole ça fait quinze jours
ci est prévue début de semaine est reçue
en triomphe
voilà il doit annoncer que ces hausses
de taxes et non être annulés sur
l'ensemble du quinquennat et je pense
qu'il doit lancer quelque chose aussi
pour nos retraités je pense à
l'augmentation de la csg je pense à la
désindexation de la retraite par an
l'inflation ça ne se faisait pas depuis
trente ans ce gouvernement a fait le
choix de paupériser encore un peu plus
pour traiter je pense qu'on doit avoir
une vraie réponse globalement sur
l'impôt la taxe et la rémunération la
colère aujourd'hui des gilets jaunes
montre qu'on a un problème de
rémunération globale dans notre pays
aujourd'hui en france qui travaille qui
ne s'en sort plus et nous politiques
d'être capable d'apporter des réponses à
sa ce problème ne vient pas
d'aujourd'hui je suis d'accord avec vous
aujourd'hui a eu l'occasion d'y répondre
parce que ce problème est soulevé
alors justement vous parlez la france
qui travaille c'est exactement les mots
du pré du premier ministre cette semaine
mardi quand il a appris la parole je
vous propose d'écouter edouard philippe
il s'exprimer et c'est quand il a
annoncé le moratoire c'était mardi
on l'écouté on revient juste après les
français qui ont enfilé un gilet jaune
aiment leur pays ils veulent que les
impôts baissent et que le travail paye
c'est aussi ce que nous voulons ce sont
aussi nos valeurs c'est le coeur de
l'engagement du président de la
république
et si je n'ai pas réussi à l'exprimer
si la majorité a peiné en convaincre les
français c'est que je dois que nous
devons changer quelque chose
[Musique]
jacques ricart d'éthique que doit
changer le gouvernement pour satisfaire
les gilet jaune et apaiser la colère
selon le rassemblement national
écoutez c'est pas selon le rassemblement
national on voit qu'il ya très
clairement des des sujets qui tombe pour
exprimer le pouvoir d'achat les
retraites les charges patronales soit
effectivement ça c'est le minimum du
minimum il était temps qu'on arrive
effectivement à ce moratoire sur les
taxes sur l'essence sans doute comme le
dit monsieur boucard un peu tard voilà
je je vois aussi que même ballot peine à
trouver le nouveau monde pour lequel
s'était engagé à écouter voilà je pense
que avec le livre évolution ça suffisait
pas la révolution là les éléments de
langage je veux bien mais en attendant
on a rien de concret donc moi en tant
que politique
moi je vais vous parler de ce que je
connais je suis maire d'une petite
commune toutes petites communes c'est 25
euros par mois d'indemnités pour gérer
cette petite commune
je suis aussi conseiller régional ça
fait plusieurs fois que j'ai un peu plus
les anglais disent un peu plus
effectivement ses 1800 euros
effectivement m on va être dans le
concret avec la réu avec la réunion des
deux régions bourgogne et franche-comté
ses 1800 euros nous demandons depuis le
début de la mandature à ce que nos
indemnités baisse baisse de 20 % pour
passer à 1400 euros s'est refusée par
l'exécutif de marie-guite dufay bon
voilà on est on fait des propositions
concrètes nous avons le budget dans peu
de temps nous allons demander à ce que
nous
tout ce qui est un des mythes et fred à
des mythes et de déplacement du mois de
décembre soit reversée à la banque
alimentaire
ça fera partie ça fera partie ça fera
partie d'un veut bien évidemment je
pense qu'il sera balayé comme l'ensemble
des voeux comme des amendements que l'on
fait là il ya une vraie crise au sida
des mots creux de la démocratie je vois
dans les exécutifs
moi je vois ça depuis peu je je je tâte
les exécutifs
elle est le monde de l'opposition je
vois quand essaye d'être constructif de
poser des amendements tels que je viens
de vous les donner
c'est à dire une baisse de 20% de nos
indemnités de nos indemnités d'élu quand
tu demandes à ce que à ce que les nos
frais de déplacement du mois de décembre
soit versée à la banque alimentaire se
sera refusée ce sera balayée voilà moi
je voudrais du concret s'ils voulaient
bien on continue le premier tour de
table de ce plateau séverine vieillesse
ne s'est pas encore exprimé on a
l'impression que la france insoumise se
réjouit de ce mouvement d gilet jaune
que vous vous y retrouvez
mais on ne peut pas enfin on peut que se
réjouir effectivement qu'à un moment
donné on est des citoyens qui reprennent
leur destin en main parce que je pense
véritablement que c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer
donc à ce niveau là oui moi je suis
réjouie de la situation et est ce que je
voudrais exprimer aujourd'hui c'est que
je considère que ce mouvement il est
beaucoup plus profond que ce que
j'entends ici dire que c'est pas un
mouvement anti taxe c'est un mouvement
qui est un point de non retour c'est à
dire c'est une remise en cause totale de
40 années de politiques néolibérales qui
ont été menées dans ce pays et c'est un
cri parce que vous avez un libéral du
gilet jaune
j'entends mais s'il vous plaît je vous
ai laissé parler vous allez me laisse
aller au bout de mon raisonnement s'il
vous plaît mais si laissez moi leo book
donc on est on est véritablement dans
une demande de justice sociale de
justice fiscale et on voit bien quand on
discute avec les gilet jaune sur les
points 2 les points de blocage
effectivement il ya un rejet
effectivement des taxes et des impôts
mais parce que il ya une inégalité entre
entre ce que ceux qui sont prélevées sur
les petites gens et ceux qui ne sont pas
prélevés sur un certain sur une certaine
population alors on doit il y ajouterait
jeu finalement jugé fini ma phrase il ya
vraiment une
comment dire une grande différence entre
l'augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires pour les petites gens et le
recul des services publics
et c'est ça qui est dénoncée va revenir
absolue et légalement institutionnels on
va revenir sur ces deux questions
séverine vieillesse mais je vous propose
tout de suite de retourner à dijon
rejoindre sébastien caire où sébastien
m'a évoqué avec vous l'une des
conséquences de ce mouvement les
conséquences sur l'activité économique
et notamment les commerçants
oui tout à fait jérémy et pour en parler
bien je me trouve dans la rue des
godrans qui se trouve à quelques
centaines de mètres de la rue de la
préfecture qui était donc le théâtre des
affrontements entre crs et gilet jaune
ce week-end et je suis avec arnaud
marion anneaux mario bougez vous vous
êtes brute versant d'enchaîner la
boutique
tout d'abord quelles ont été les
conséquences directes de ce mouvement
sur votre chiffre d'affaires les
conséquences directes c'est qu'il ya
très peu de monde
c'est du moins 50 moins 55 exactement
donc c'est sachant que mois de décembre
est l'un des plus importants de l'année
pour nous ces deux mois on fait deux
mois et demi on en a moins de points 55
c'est c'est l'équivalent pour moi d'un
mois 55% à chaque chiffre d'affaires et
c'est l'équivalent d'un mois de mai
salaires sur 12 mois
donc je vais donc bien décembre si ça
continue si ça perdure c'est stressant
mais comment vous le vivez vous ce
mouvement vous êtes dans une situation
un peu compliquée on l'a compris c'est
anxiogène c'est très anxiogène c'est
dans quand vous sortez dans la rue des
godrans la semaine dernière notamment la
police à gaz et les gens les gens
étaient paniqués et en a qui sont entrés
dans le magasin j'ai été gazés pour la
première fois de ma vie entre guillemets
ça fait un drôle d'effet et et il y
avait des gens qui étaient très qui
n'était pas bien quoi qui pleurait et
c'est à moi dans la boutique ça allait à
peu près mais c'est vrai que dans la rue
ce n'est pas simple et du coup il ya une
ambiance anxiogène peu
les samedis on a peur d'ailleurs on a
peur qu'on nous casse notre vitrine ça
manquerait montré plus que ça encore
voilà ça c'est assez angoissant
merci beaucoup arnaud marion et
justement on est avec un autre
commerçant antoine vestiaire qui est
également le trésorier de l'association
village godrans l'association des
commerçants
vous êtes une cinquantaine de
commerçants dans cette rue tout le monde
a subi la même chose que carnot marion
c'est à dire des pertes de chiffres
d'affaires
peut-être des vitrines cassées outre un
vitrines cassées heureusement comme
disait un nouveau nom en effet hier la
semaine dernière c'était un peu chaud
cette semaine va ce ça a été un peu
longue ou parce que c'est un mot c'était
vraiment leur se voit nous envoie
régulièrement des textos la police
rentrez vous
rentrez vos terrasses donc c'est assez
une ambiance en effet en a on a peur un
peu qui se passe des débordements
surtout que la semaine dernière en effet
il ya eu quand même des petits moments
de panique dans la rue globalement oui
et une baisse on n'a pas tous été
impacté la même façon heureusement pas
surtout tout ce qui est vraiment lié aux
achats de noël des accessoires des
choses comme ça c'est comme version le
plus long le plus pris sur le banc vous
avez peur que ça continue aujourd'hui
ah bah oui puis comme c'est parti en
vrille à valoir encore je pense sur les
deux week-ends prochains qui nous c'est
de week-end en plus ils auront sera
ouvert les dimanches pour pour les fêtes
de noël
donc pour nous en tant que commerçant
s'est scellée pu essayer moments les
plus importants certains sont moins
impactés new skies et magasins de
nourriture ou là ils sont beaucoup moins
sabatier mais même moi où je n'avais pas
été impactées jusque là ça y est on a
bien bien senti qu à les rues étaient
vides et ça c'est pas c'est pas évident
merci beaucoup et bon courage pour la
suite vous la jérémy ce qu'on pouvait
dire à propos des commerçants qui sont
confrontés à ce mouvement dès gilet
jaune
merci beaucoup sébastien on va faire
réagir tout de suite les gilet jaune sur
ce plateau c'est les rois on est à 15
jours de noël qu'est ce que vous
répondez aux petits commerçants là qu'on
a qu'on a vu qu'ils ont un chiffre
d'affaires en chute libre depuis le
début de votre mouvement
alors moi j'ai été voir mes petits
commerçants du centre-ville du marché
les jeudis et
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on entend là
alors certes ils sont en baisse de
chiffre et vous contestez les pertes de
chiffre d'affaires de non pas du tout
ils sont offerts deux chiffres du sur
hbo en gilet jaune mais le problème qui
a c'est que la perte de chiffre là elle
elle était déjà sur des années
auparavant c'est pas depuis calais gilet
jaune qu'ils ont une perte de chiffre
deuxièmement si on se bat pour ça c'est
parce que les gens n'ont plus d'argent à
aller consommer chez nos commerçants on
appelait pouvoir d'achat donc certes là
ils sont en perte de chiffre et vous
savez mais moi personnellement j'ai
toujours pas commencé mes cadeaux de
noël
donc c'est qu'à un moment donné il ya
c'est vous guettent sur les ronds-points
vous n'avez pas l'âge aidant les cours
mais c'est et nous nos commerçants on y
est et de commerçants nous ont à faire
des choses du pain d épices et des
choses qui confectionnent eux-mêmes et
ont sortis eux aussi leur gilet jaune on
dit c'est pas grave on perd de l'argent
y perdre énormément d'argent
mais si c'est pour aller mieux après il
n'y a pas que les petits commerçants qui
sont qui conte des soucis liés liées au
mouvement je vous propose d'écouter tout
de suite un responsable de centre
commercial est aussi un responsable
d'une entreprise de transport que nos
équipes ont rencontré ces derniers jours
sur le terrain on écoute et on réagit
juste après ça devient catastrophique
pour un la trésorerie de la gestion de
aussi bien des temps de travail que
notre clientèle puisque une cliente est
livré en retard ou pas libre et
puisqu'on est des camions qui arrivent à
être bloquée complètement et voir faire
demi tour
leurs revendications on les comprend
par contre la cible est pas bonne c'est
des prix s'attaque aux commerçants nous
on a des salariés qu'on doit payer
aujourd'hui je mets en doute la
pérennité de certaines structures
[Musique]
l'économie tétanisé fabrique légal ça
fait aussi réagir nos internautes et nos
téléspectateurs une question que benoît
nous a envoyé en bloquant les zones
commerciales les gilets jaunes font le
jeu d'amazon et casse le pouvoir d'achat
des salariés qui vont voir leurs primes
annulé faute de clients alors ça c'est
possible on va partir parce que chez un
petit doigt c'est largement possible que
l'économie d'ailleurs d'ailleurs ccc
très problématique parce que la
croissance était déjà très faible
monsieur macro nous avait promis une
belle croissance
on n'était qu'un tel que cette l'année
dernière là je pense qu'on va encore
perdre peut-être 03 05
suite à ces événements on n'en parle pas
mais c'est encore de l'argent qui va
falloir trouver en plus donc des impôts
qu'il va falloir encore créé alors nous
à dole on parle avec nos commerçants
parce que ils ont évidemment le problème
de cette actualité anxiogène qui
n'invitent pas à dépenser son argent
mais aussi je leur ai fait remarquer que
c'est tout à fait normal d'être dans un
pays où quand on travaille quand on est
une entreprise qu'on a travaillé et
c'est au bout de trois semaines où la
période n'est pas bonne on est déjà au
bord du dépôt de bilan
pourquoi parce que cette fiscalité nous
prend tous toute l'année et que dès
qu'il ya un petit accroc on a développé
mais vous comprenez la grande de vous
êtes chef d'entreprise je vous le
promets je veux dire la l'économie elle
tourne un peu au ralenti
c'est pour ça qu'on fait des opérations
dans le jura ce week-end c'est le jura
free c'est à dire que là vous pouvez
aller faire vos courses dans le jura
parce que on paye par l'autoroute
et puis nos commerçants on distribue des
tracts pour acheter local voilà et donc
j'en profite pour le dire parce que on a
une réunion qui s'est bien déroulée
vendredi au début c'était un petit peu
tendu après on a on a remarqué qu'on
était tous victimes de ce système
intolérable intolérable parce qu'on est
arrivé vraiment
un point ou alors changer les choses ou
pas avec des mesurettes et donc nos
commerçants ils font ils font comme ils
peuvent
voilà une autre réaction sur internet à
l'opposé des précédentes pour le coup
agnès qui nous dit ce ne sont pas les
gilet jaune qui m'empêche d'aller
consommer mon revenu 790 euros charges
sans la nourriture sans l'essence 890
euros donc là si je ne trouve pas
rapidement un travail à temps plein je
ne sais pas comment je vais pouvoir
manger la peur des fins de mois le
pouvoir d'achat c'est la revendication
majeure des gilet jaune depuis le début
du mouvement écouter ces quelques
témoignages recueillis ces dernières
semaines en bourgogne franche comté
je suis une vache à lait comme tous les
français où beaucoup tout simplement
et puis elle a ras-le-bol des taxes des
taxes des taxes markets abaissé
maintenant tout augmente quitté
personnes qui travaillent
sur les salaires on gagne elles doivent
en donner une grande partie à l'état
dans les taxes dans les impôts et il
leur reste à peine à certains à peine
pour survivre là on peut plus vivre on
est pris à la gorge
il faut qu'on rachète des voitures mais
avec quoi nous fait des efforts tout le
temps on les paye ces taxes mêlant tout
ok j'ai des apl
ok j'ai une bourse une fois que j'ai
payé mon loyer et mon électricité
je suis déjà à moins 10 euros donc j'ai
encore pas acheté de stylos pour aller
en cours ni même une feuille ni même à
manger les gens ils galèrent tous à
pourvoir faire la fin du mois un gars
qui vivent avec leur salaire y verra
bien avec 1200 euros tu pourras pas loin
je travaille de nuit pour 1300 euros de
salaire voilà et les taxe qu'on a
donc nous nous ronge la vie quoi on se
bat aussi bien pour avoir une vie un peu
meilleure qu'au retour en plateau si
vous nous rejoignez c'est dimanche en
politique spéciale gilet jaune sur
france 3 bourgogne et france 3 franche
comté une émission que vous pouvez
commenter sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le mode yes dit mme paul bfc comme
dimanche en politique bourgogne franche
comté avoir une vie un peu meilleure
c'est le combat des gilet jaune
est ce que c'est un endroit vous vous
retrouvez dans les témoignages que l'on
vient d'entendre complètement
actuellement les avants on avait les
ouvriers qui vous agréent avec sa robe
et les agriculteurs qui oscille faisait
grève deux fois dans l'année où diverses
le purin et c'est maintenant qu'on soit
actifs retraités qu'on est une
entreprise qu'on fasse des heures sup
etc on se retrouve toujours pris à la
gorge à la fin du mois alors c'est celle
là qui à ce problème de fiscalité
c'est qu'au final est-ce qu'on doit
travailler pour toujours essayer de
gagner plus on dit toujours que le
travailleur à ce but de devenir riche et
qui ne viendra jamais parce que il faire
bosser bosser bosser et au final on
n'est pas qu'on ne pas remercier du tout
il ya les travailleurs pauvres qui eux
bossent
plus qu'un acharnement et n'y arrive
toujours pas non plus il ya un sentiment
d'être laissés pour compte
complètement mais moi tout à fait toutes
les personnes que je parle actuellement
c'est cette voie là on les a laissés sur
le bas côté et on a la tête dans le
guidon en avant c'est parce qu'on perd
on perd est-ce qu'on peut le minimum
qu'on peut gagner on le gagnera quoi et
ses semis prix là c'est cet abandon lac
et personne ne supporte plus en fait
barbara beso ballot il ya une france qui
est abandonnée par le pouvoir par les
élites ou en tout cas qui a le sentiment
d'être abandonnés afin qu'ils aient le
sentiment d'être abandonnés encore une
fois on a entendu que des vérités viens
d'entendre que des vérités
c'est sur la manière de faire est de
proposer qu'on n'est pas tout mais c'est
pas parce que c'est un sentiment qu'il
faut pas le traiter j'ai entendu on
aurait dû l'annoncer ya quinze jours
si on l'avait annoncé il ya quinze jours
je rappelle juste qu'on est en pleine
crise écologique ou l'oubli mais nous
sommes en pré une crise écologique alors
sur la gamme n'ont cependant pas
l'action à côté de ça non j'ai pris des
notes pour une fois répondre à l'est il
ya quinze jours nous avions annoncé il
ya quinze jours le la motion de
moratoire pour geler tout ça on ne leur
ait dit ça y est vous reculez c'est tout
ce qu'on aurait retenu
ça veut dire que le gouvernement a
reculé finalement face à la violence de
la rue peine à vous avez attendu
non mais attendez c'est super parce que
en fait vous vouliez pas court qu il ya
quinze jours mais en fait on nous avait
attendu les débordements des derniers
week-ends pour sceller à l'armée non on
n'a pas attendu
quand on voit la violence il n'était pas
question effectivement qu'on recule il
n'était pas question que le guen
puisqu'on était dans le dans tout ce que
vous êtes en train de dire que ça leur
nous étions là dedans et nous y sommes
toujours là dedans ça va mais laps de
temps quand vous avez dit tout à la
banque
rajoutant des taxes regardez une manière
un peu plus factuel avec un oeil tout de
même ça tombe bien allez-y l'elysée
prenez les deux alors on a deux yeux
deux oreilles c'est peut-être pour
regarder deux fois plus qu'on ait que
deux fois plus qu'on ne parle jamais
mais écoutez de faux pas leur dit nous
voir et cela dit nous voir vous avez
parlé de peiner à trouver le nouveau
monde
ça fait 18 mois dix-huit mois que nous
sommes là vous connaissez vous un enfant
qui nait et qui passe son bac à 18 ans
ont tout de suite ça peut connaissez
mais vous connaissez enfin vous
connaissez ce qui fonctionne au bout de
une aubaine puisque au matin il faut
j'ai visité une entreprise comme la com
la société franchisée jae liquidation
judiciaire ou pas j'ai visité nous
sommes d'accord il faut qu'une
entreprise mais la france n'est pas
d'une start up on est d'accord il faut
du temps où son bout des choses écologie
ne peut pas être punitive madame les
causes l'écologie encore une fois nous
devons trouver des solutions mobiles
entre les traditions du bifff jeu que
vous avez voté contre l'amendement
bourgois j'ai voté contre lui faisait
toujours est il que vous avez voté pour
moi j'ai voté contre mais bien non non
non seulement je sais le glyphosate
n'est pas le débat
cbre immédiate mais néanmoins le
gouvernement à reculer sur notamment la
taxe carbone la trajectoire que ce qu'on
appelle la trajectoire carbone les
rattrapages le fiscalité gasoil et
essence
est ce que comme disait un certain
président de la république l'écologie ça
commence à bien faire
parce que finalement c'est là dessus que
le gouvernement mais mais mais oui mais
le gouvernement à reculer la tenue va
même pas être à partie les que
l'écologisme et c'est là dessus que vous
avez retenu
c'est une vision voilà vous le dis vous
le dites vous-même vous dites oui c'est
là dessus que vous avez reculé on n'a
pas reculé un moment donné il ya
tellement de violence s'est gâté il faut
revoir la copie c'est ce qu'a dit
edouard philippe et ses jeux menacé une
gestion à la petite semaine
vous voulez vous voulez non non non pas
sous les jets mécènes qui arrive de la
société civile et en même temps vous
nous traitez d'amateurs j'ai ce dernier
chez tous âges c'est un peu amateur la
salle de bain je ne sais pas si c'est
pas une entreprise et en excuser peinant
à trouver à bab mon entreprise va très
bien j'ai de voir qu'elle va continuer à
aller très bien
est ce que ce sont les deux les deux
choses que je vais tenter de faire
pendant ce mandat
bell a trouvé le nouveau monde ça fait
18 mois que nous sommes là donc il n'ya
pas de pena treuil non justement en 18
mois quelle économie inite conviendra
prendre le destin sapri fait prendre
destin en main vous savez on a entendu
destination du la destitution du
président de la république
la dissolution de l'assemblée mais ça ne
nous pose aucun problème non mais je ne
sais pas madame et parce que dans
l'énoncé bon sens comme une dame qui a
dit à juste titre cédant laisser dans
les bureaux de vote et n'oubliez pas que
vous avez que nous avons effectivement
le pouvoir de voter les gens ont voté
pour que je sois à l'assemblée nationale
selon madame dans quelles conditions
j'aimerais j'aimerais correct sur les
questions et j'aimerais qu'on va être
sur les questions de pouvoir d'achat je
vous promets qu'on va venir aux
questions institutionnelles au slogan
qu'on entend sur le mac ronde émission
qu on entend énormément sur sur les
ronds points les rassemblements de gilet
jaune juste une réaction de nicolas vous
l'avez vu à l'antenne les gilet jaune
ont ils conscience de leur inculture
économique ils demandent une baisse
massive des charges et des taxes et une
hausse tout aussi massive des dépenses
publiques comment on fait et ce que les
gillet jour j'aimerais laisserait bien à
cette question si vous l'oreille réponse
vous y répondre et après après les gilet
jaune de combat sur le plateau parce que
c'est eux qui sont visés monsieur
schlegel mais non mais comment on peut
dire ça comment on peut dire ça tiens on
peut me le remettre là que je relise
exactement a dit je vous lis on va le
remettre à l'antenne c'est nicolas ces
prêts elle est prête la palette regarder
les gilets jaunes ont ils conscience de
leur inculture économique
il demande à la fois une baisse massive
des charges et des taxes mais une hausse
tout aussi maintenant juger mon
désistement et dépenses publiques et je
vais en profiter pour dire et redire que
la situation actuelle ne pourra pas être
résolue par par des idées du 20e siècle
c'est non non non non parce que c'est
assez cocasse quand même que les gens
d'extrême gauche moyenne engagé
politiquement avec des valeurs bien
rouges précieux non simplement
donc je suis pas en train de dire ce que
je lis ça je suis pas en train de vous
dire que vous êtes extrêmement entre
mois le site
je suis pas en train de vous dire que
vous êtes d'extrême centre bouquet vous
respecter mon esprit mais lui il assume
c'est un gilet jaune qui assume d'être
de droite à gauche mais j'assume est
également moins on fasse en sorte
d'arrêter de me donner une étiquette que
je n'ai pas eu d'accord c'est vous et
c'est bien pour bien nous avons plutôt
positif d'assimilation hockey en tout
cas vous êtes agressif je peux vous le
dire c'est parce qu'il n'arrêtait pas de
couper la parole monsieur ne peut pas en
placer une
mais bon c'est bien céline roy céline
roy j'aimerais j'aimerais entendre
céline ouamer vous me l'avez idées de
monsieur nana là on a compris que vous
comptez astier ce paradoxe est stone ya
un paradoxe céline roy a demandé à la
fois une baisse des taxes une baisse des
charges et plus de services publics plus
de dépenses publiques
alors moi ce qui me fait rire dans ça
c'est que est ce que le gouvernement a
conscience de ce qui se passe
actuellement
alors certes toutes nos revendications
ne sont pas bonnes et ne seront pas dans
tous les cas réaliser parce qu'il ya des
choses qui sont qui sont trop à
l'extrême mais
si les gens partent autant à l'extrême
c'est ya bien un sérieux problème il ya
un noyau qu'il faut et complètement
éclaté parce que si les gens arrivent à
cet extrême là quand j'entends qu'il
faut un smic à 2000 euros
c'était un moment donné les gens il leur
faut des 1000 euros en chemise pour
pouvoir finir leurs fins de mois
donc c'est là où il faut se poser de
sérieuses questions
alors certes on est peut-être
irrationnel sur tout non toutes nos
revendications je rappelle qu'on est con
n'est pas politique donc on n'est pas
des pros mais c'est ça qui c'est moi ce
qui m'inquiète encore plus alors céline
roy justement vous dites on n'est pas
politique mais ce qu'on observe c'est
qu'il ya des tentatives de récupération
politique
je vais vous montrer des réactions
d'élus de bourgogne franche comté julien
houde où le président du groupe
rassemblement national à la région
bourgogne franche comté c'est le
président de votre groupe jacques ricart
des ti il nous dit le rassemblement
national avait raison avant les autres
il est le seul recours démocratique pour
sortir de cette crise gabriel amard
candidat de la france a soumis ce
jurassien candidat aux européennes dans
quelques mois les gilet jaune demandent
la démission du monarque
la révocation des politiques en place à
charge pour nous de le traduire
politiquement comment vous sur les ronds
points sur les rassemblements gilet
jaune vous réagissez à ça alors moi je
trouve ça complètement aberrant surfer
sur la misère des gens pour essayer de
se faire une place
moi ça me dégoûte au plus haut point
alors certes c'est la bonne occasion
pour ce faire justement entendent espère
un petit peu de pub mais quand je vois
que des partisans du front national
rassemblement national chez moi sont
venus agresser des gilets jaunes
moi personnellement je me dis que la
pousse à vesoul à vesoul
il ya des plaintes qui ont été déposées
etc je pense que c'est on le répète
depuis le début qu'on n'a pas de
syndicats qu'on n'a pas de parti
politique malgré qu'on en fasse en face
moi ça me met pareil pour monsieur
mélenchon pareil pour tout allait bien
justement on va les faire répondre
jacques richiardi qui vous essayer de
récupérer le mouvement dont on les
récupère rien du tout simplement il ya
une désespérance je poserai je ne
poserai surtout pas les gilet jaune sur
les barricades et lé gilet jaune
commerçants pas plus que je ne poserai
les gilet jaune petit et lucky qui se
battent pour pour défendre l'intérêt
l'intérieur de leur commune ou d'une
petite collectivité voilà moi je fais
pas d'opposition simplement
effectivement c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'on peut c'est ce que nous nous
appelons le le pays central et qui est
majoritaire autour de cette table autour
de cette table nous sommes tous un peu
des gilet jaune
sans vouloir le récupérer chacun chacun
a sa motivation pour pour être
mécontents moi en tant que petit élu qui
suit aussi un salarié et je ne poserai
pas un commerçant si un commerçant ou
une profession libérale derrière il n'y
a pas d'opposition simplement certaines
mesures de bon sens ne sont pas
appliquées nous vous les connaissez ce
serait plutôt les nôtres avant les
autres simplement dans les mesures et la
politique c'est des choix et si vous
voulez si vous voulez qu'on arrive à
quelque chose il ya qu'un seul choix qui
peut s'imposer
c'est la démocratie et la démocratie il
faut que les gens soient représentés
vous moi et les autres
si c'est pas le cas on arrive à des
explosions j'écris récupère rien du tout
et on récupère à rien du tout sa
séverine béziers cabrials allah a laissé
entendre fin non clairement d'ailleurs
il n'a pas laissé entendre a dit
clairement que c'était une opportunité
politique pour la france insoumise le
mouvement des gilet jaune il a pas il
n'a pas fait la phrase que vous avez mis
en évidence il ay parle pas de porte
unité politique
si j'y étais j'ai été à la conférence de
presse ce sont ses mots
alors là je vous l'assuré vous y mettiez
aussi en tant que mouvement politique
on a un discours politique à tenir et
force est de constater parce qu'en tant
que citoyen on participe également aux
barrages on est nombreux à besançon à
participer aux barrages en tant que
gilet jaune et donc par en tant que
prince sont soumises met véritablement
en tant que citoyen et on discute avec
les gens et on voit bien qu'il ya un
certain nombre de revendications qui
correspondent à des revendications qu'on
a porté en 2017
et c'est ça juste qu'on dit est un
moment donné le mouvement il
n'appartient à personne et il ne faut
pas qu'ils appartiennent à qui que ce
soit il sera en pl s'il n'appartient à
personne et je vais rebondir par rapport
à la question de la fiscalité
la question c'est l'inégalité fiscale
il ya trop de textes sur un certain
nombre de deux français c'est évident
mais la question de la fiscalité c'est
une question de répartition de cette
fiscalité
quand on voit que plus de 54 % des
recettes fiscales sont déliées à la tva
quels impôts qu'ils attaquent la plus
injuste qui est forfaitaire
nous on prône la progressivité de
l'impôt sur le revenu et on fait ans on
aimerait qu'il y ait 14 tranche d'impôt
sur le revenu donc la question de la
fiscalité sec la fiscalité il faut tout
revoir la politique fiscale doit être
revu de fond en comble allez on continue
à avancer dans ce débat une autre
rengaine et répétés sur les ronds-points
c'est le rejet des élites en général et
du président de la république en
particulier par le gilet jaune
on ne veut pas de mouvements politiques
nick syndicats nous c'est le peuple
simplement défendre nos droits parce
qu'on crève de faim on en a ras-le-bol
de ce gouvernement qui se gavent sur
nous sur nous sur tout le monde ici ça a
été commencé par macro qui a fait
exploser le parti politique
et maintenant c'est un peu le revers de
la médaille qui montre que justement les
gens ne croient plus aux politiques des
autres tous les partis politiques
différents et finalement bas à la fin
d'apprendre qu'ils mangent tous ensemble
donc voila quand faut arrêter quoi
arrêter vont arrêter de prendre les gens
pour des idiots
il a perdu toute légitimité a noté à nos
yeux
en plus le non respect vis-à-vis de nous
ce mépris c'est pas en nous tournant le
dos et on sent comme si on n'existait
pas et c'est vraiment photos nues
des bus jusqu'à maintenant quoi et je
sais pas si c'est rattrapable là
franchement c'est pour moi c'est pas
rattrapable du tout on est parti dans
une crise de l'institution une crise
d'institutions dénonce les gilet jaune
est ce que fabrique légal vous avait
clamé ce slogan comme beaucoup de gilet
jaune macron démission ah non non non
non non on est en démocratie alors je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec sa
manière de fonctionner mais je crois que
nos revendications pour pas qu'elle soit
farfelues parce que on imagine macro où
ils arrivent déjà même pas reculer sur
sur un chiffre alors vous pensez bien
qu'il va pas rentrer dans l'histoire en
étant le premier président à
démissionner faut pas y compter ça mais
ça veut dire parce que enfin c'est le
slogan qu'on entend majoritairement
aujourd'hui l'entente majoritairement
non mais ça c'est pour se faire plaisir
ça c'est la dissolution du sénat c'est
pareil pour faire plaisir mais céline
roy même question non moi je prône avec
fierté mon slogan macron démission parce
que je n'accepte pas tout simplement
qu'un président qui est censé
représenter son peuple méprise autant
les citoyens quand la france est en fait
monsieur n'est pas là ne prend pas la
parole et c'est ça c'est en fait
pourquoi ça pète autant c'est parce
qu'il ya un mépris et un mépris des plus
totales de la personne qui sont si nous
écouter nous représentait en fait tout
simplement sans nous actuellement il
serait pas là et l'a donc vous assumez
macron démission et donc
imaginons ils démissionneront mais qui à
la place un général comme le que le
revendique un des porte-parole de gilet
jaune
il ya quelques jours sur un plateau de
télévision parce qu'en fait moi je suis
pas assez encore formaté politique
pourra dire voilà telle et telle
personne serait légitime de nous
représenter actuellement mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que maintenant je doute
fortement qu'il est encore sa place
oui les infirmes barbara bessat on a
beaucoup de réactions notamment quand
est-ce que macron démissionne est ce que
vous vous avez la réponse à cette
question il faut toujours être prudent
ok macro il y en a qui prône ses parts
qui pour le remplacer qui avec kir
pouvoir parler derrière avec qui vous
savez même dans le monde associatif tout
le monde est en train de critiquer le
président de l'association qui peut
remplacer le président et là on parle de
bénévolat on parle de bénévolat mais
j'ai eu c'est ce que les hélices âge les
élites barbara baisse au balo les
responsables politiques ne jouent pas se
faire peur on a eu guillaume larrivé
député de l'yonne qui a dit cette
semaine ce qui compte plus que tout
c'est préserver la paix civile il est
membre de l'opposition il et les
républicains et de sauver les vies
la rupture avec le maquereau nice ne
doit pas se faire par le chaos françois
patriat le patron du groupe
la république est en marche sénateur de
haute saône de côte-d'or pardon nous
sommes dans une situation de volonté de
putsch danielle brulebois députés
eux-mêmes du jura le président de la
république ne devrait pas avoir à
appeler à l'union nationale dans une
démocratie quand vous criez pas au loup
quand même vous pensez vraiment que les
institutions sont en danger
oui à russell je le pense que les
institutions sont en danger oui je le
pense
en tout cas les dernières semaines nous
démontre qu'il ya sans doute un danger
et il faut avoir cette vigilance là il
faut tout de même avoir sévi ces cieux
aussi c'est le dénommé le danger alesi
le chat de rasoir tout mettre en bas
sans avoir l'idée de la reconstruction
derrière alors une question qui vous est
adressée mal acquis si je peux me
permettre en avait en début de mandat un
hyper président à présent la république
et est un renard aujourd'hui on a besoin
de lui quand on a besoin on a besoin d'à
présent la république qui réagit nous
étions des dispositions qui répond à la
colère légitime des français est
aujourd'hui ce qui lui arrive c'est la
résultante du mépris qu'il a eu pour les
français depuis mai 2010 elle les a
mangés l'outil les dahlias moment voilà
voilà ce que fait aujourd'hui les
illettrés de gad voilà ce que paie
aujourd'hui manuel mâcon et au moment où
on a besoin de lui il n'est plus là il
disparaît et c'est pas général de
l'équivalent de 90 des manuels macron
qui est retranché à l'elysée ou à
versailles et on a eu un débat
surréaliste malbaie ce ballon plan
qu'elle parlait mercredi
on a parlé pendant cinq heures à
l'international des possibilités pour
sortir de crise on a un premier ministre
chef du gouvernement qui annonce un
moratoire sur les carburants
l'opposition tout le monde appelle de
ses voeux à ce que toutes les taxes
soient gelés et on apprend au dérobé par
françois de rugy une heure et demie
après à la télé qu'il a reçu un sms
d'emmanuel macron disant qu'ils
pouvaient dire ça donc on a un premier
ministre aujourd'hui qui ne sert plus à
rien alors peut-être que mal qu'on ne va
pas démissionner aujourd'hui en tout cas
on a un gouvernement qui ne fonctionne
plus et on n'est le cas que vous accusez
yanbu car en tant que député vous êtes
favorable à la démission vous vous
appelez la démission du chef de l'état
renens moi en tant que député je me pose
la question évidemment de pas d'appeler
la démission du chef de l'état il fera
bien ce qu'il veut mais il a été élu
démocratiquement et moi je suis
légitimiste pour autant aujourd'hui il
faut constater qu'on a un gouvernement
qui ne fonctionne plus avec quelqu'un
qui a sa tête qui n'a même plus
l'assentiment du président de la
république parce que c'est ça qui s'est
passé mercredi une une question qui
vient d'arriver république est à bout de
souffle
globalement de toute façon donc venez
sur l'urban de la france justement une
question institutionnelle qui était
adressé à madame vaisseau ballot valérie
madame vaisseau ballot elle vous
interpelle directement madame vaisseau
ballot pense-t-elle encore qu'à ce jour
l'assemblée nationale est représentatif
d'une majorité de français vraie
question représente-t-elle uniquement
emmanuel malraux est ce que vous pouvez
répondre à valérie s'il vous plaît
barbara b ce ballot société civile s'est
jamais jamais été encarté politiquement
auparavant je suis quoi je suis partie
des 300 sièges je ne me résous
l'assemblée nationale
et voilà donc aux personnes qui
représentent on l'a fait les gestes les
gens ont voté
nous faisons partie des 314 personnes
qui représentant la france est derrière
nous on se fait traiter de moutons
passer de ces exactement moi je dis
c'est dommage j'écoute valeurs que vous
êtes très bien et et je suis sûr que
vous n'avez pas voix au chapitre on vous
dit il faut voter comme ça pour voter
comme ça par contre là il nous reste
gratuit ok rendant comme moi je dirais
plutôt juste de parler nous restons très
peu le temps paramé raison tout des
problèmes mais le tout monsieur sénégal
pour ces gens c'est souvent voilà est-ce
qu'on fait pour six retraités qui
n'arrivent plus à boucler les salariés
nedim avec de m'opposer juste le
montréal en mai les foules chez votre
politique vous êtes ensuite pourquoi je
suis si vous parlez tous ensemble on
n'entend personne sans talent c'est moi
qui pose les questions monsieur ch légal
qu'est ce qui vous ferait rentrer chez
vous qu'est ce qui vous ferait stopper
le mouvement
très concrètement alors c'est très très
simple s'il faut pas mettre la charrue
avant les boeufs moi je suis en train
d'écrire tout ça il va maintenant
déjà on ne dépense pas plus que ce que
l'on gagne voilà points
1 parce qu'en france ce n'est pas de
moyens dont nous manquons et qui lit je
n'ai pas de moyens et non non vous êtes
vous êtes en déficit vous avez un
déficit de deux sets et c'est de
l'idéologie c'est ce que pense que la
france ne sait pas où va notre argent et
dans le même temps on voit des gens qui
souffrent on voit des gens qui souffrent
qui n'arrivent plus à vivre j'aimerais
dans vos discours c'est bien beau
trouver des solutions d'évasion fiscale
80 milliards d'évasion fiscale roi même
sessegnon de dividendes distribués en
2018 il ya de l'argent il faut aller le
chercher
voilà la 19ème siècle nos traditions de
disette chances de céline roy vous
qu'est ce qui vous ferait arrêter le
mouvement
moi je pense que la lésion coupleurs
marocains vous parle il n'y a pas que je
pense que quand les petits retraités
montgeron décemment que plus personne ne
sera dans la misère coordonnera les 5
euros d'apl aux personnes qui sont aux
minima sociaux et qu'on rétablira lisf
parce que quand on dit que l' isf c'est
pour faire venir les grosses boîtes en
france alors qu on ne pense plus à nos
petits artisans ça ça me fait très mal
voilà je pense que déjà là on aura fait
un très beau bon et je pense qu'on n'ira
déjà beaucoup mieux à ce moment là
barbara beso vélo il va annoncer quoi le
président de la république demain ou
après-demain là quand il va s'exprimer
puisqu'il reste book très peu de temps
mettons nous autour de la table quelles
solutions apporter pour payer moins
d'impôts et avoir un maximum de la
céline roy voulait proposer des pistes
mais bien ça oui alors attendez attendez
monsieur chez les gays j'aimerais bien
que barbare abessolo puisse s'exprimer
sur l' isf vous en avait parlé lisf par
exemple c'est une spécificité française
effective effectivement nous avons nous
sommes toujours dans le fait de dire les
chefs n'a pas été supprimée l'été
transformé sur les capitaux sur
l'immobilier nous avons gardé les sfx et
même sur les fils qui s'appelle
maintenant livre sur les capitaux qui
sur des cartons cuba je voudrais juste
dire ce que et c'est le gouvernement
mais revenir là-dessus la fuite de ces
de ces foyers fiscaux qui sont partis à
l'extérieur soit disant qu'on perd trop
de 30 milliards de revenus malades et
non c'est ça que nous cherchons c'est ça
il faut que ça revienne un jour que ça
revienne pour que les droits très
rapidement dernière intervention qu'est
ce que vous attendez du discours du
président de la république demain ou
après demain
alors on attend toujours un miracle
c'est comme quand on joue le ça veut
dire c'est moi qui croyais à gagner non
j'y crois plus du tout
j'y crois qu un instant si c'est pour
qu'il nous annonce encore six mois que
j'ai sur sur les taxes de gasoil ou un
non ou peut-être que quand tu verras que
ça pète vraiment on aura deux ans de gel
et que dans cinq ans ça va tripler
quadrupler
ça va être génial merci ce sera le mot
de la fin merci à tous les six d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci aussi à
sébastien kérou qui était en direct du
centre ville de dijon dans cette
émission
merci à vous aussi de nous suivre vous
êtes toujours très nombreux les études
d'audimat le prouve
vous choisissez votre télévision
régionale pour vous informer
prioritairement depuis le d
but du mouvement merci de votre
confiance je vous souhaite de bien
profiter de votre dimanche et à très
bientôt sur france 3 bourgogne et france
3 franche comté
[Musique]